oh salut mon nom est Andy
Robin, rencontrons-nous bien, donc le
premier téléviseur de l'émission, vous les gars ici,
c'est l'un de nos nouveaux modèles qui utilise une
bande-annonce qui joue en 1080p normal en
ce moment, je vais le passer en 4k
qui est le  nouvelle technologie bien quelle est
la plus grande différence qu'ils voient comme
améliorer plus de variantes Libye
cela semble presque réaliste ouais
ouais j'ai trois rébus à promouvoir donc si
vous me demandez quelle école a fait celui-
là d'accord bien sûr oh mon dieu qu'en
pensez-vous  la terre les vêtements fixes
qu'il ressemble il va sauter
ma définition qui est juste là qui
est juste là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]